you've probably heard of sous-vide
that's the technique for cooking where
you seal the food inside a plastic bag
and then put it in low temperature water
so that it cooks more evenly you can
hack one of those systems together at
home or you could buy this aliso set up
to about 500 bucks looks like something
you'd find on the International Space
Station if NASA had the money to send
cooking equipment into space you get a
device that pulls the air out of plastic
bags and then this induction burner and
this beautiful tank but sous-vide has
one little problem so we did this steak
I think this is going to be beautiful to
eat but it looks not great and it looks
not great because it doesn't look
charged I didn't put this on a fire so
you don't get that beautiful my yard
reaction you don't get the grill marks
you don't get the burn which is a bummer
but I can fix that problem with fire
this is the $160 a Sancerre sear and it
is basically a home Plinko
we've you guys got a fire extinguisher
right I love this part I don't see how
this could go wrong
all right
we think here now we'll see that's so
that's beautiful
we're more consistent than I would have
got it on the grill there need fork
it's definitely a different consistency
than like if you just put it right on
the grill bill it's definitely more kind
of the same throughout you wouldn't get
that effect except on the sous vide but
having a mountaintop that makes a huge
difference just in terms of like how
appetizing that is at the top it's
really a good-looking steak
so there you have it cooking with fire
is cooking with science plus I suppose
if it was underdone you could always
just go in again